And they say,
look,
you know,
we're in real trouble unless someone goes out there and confronts tire Matt
Straight on,
she's going to wipe everything out.
It's a dangerous and terrifying job,
but somebody has to do it.
And Mark says,
oh,
that's no problem,
but I got a few rules here and this is the first rule.
Hi,
I'm in charge from here on forward.
What does that mean exactly?
Well,
these archaic stories,
our policy in our policy policymakers in Northrup fries terminology,
and what that means is that they can be read validly at multiple levels of
analysis simultaneously.
And so one thing it means is that if you take the two year old child who's
essentially under the dominion of assorted primordial Gods and Goddesses,
right?
Aggression,
fear,
panic,
and according to Freud,
a certain degree of sexual aggression,
the child moves from domination,
from motivated state to domination for motivated state.
And it isn't until the age of three and four when under the pressure applied by
the social world.
And as a consequence of the maturation of the prefrontal Cortex,
which matures throughout childhood and adolescence,
and doesn't reach its final form until perhaps into the early twenties,
all of those fundamental motivational force to start taking on a structured
relationship to one another,
which is to say that once your,
as your personality becomes integrated,
a single motive force forward has to bring all of these underlying motivational
systems into some sort of harmonious arrangement.
Okay,
so let's,
let's see what the Sumerians are doing here.
Okay.
First of all,
they're,
they're doing psychology.
They're trying to figure out,
given the dominion of the elder gods,
the indisputable dominion of the elder gods instincts.
Who should rule,
right?
What should be in charge,
how do you construct the hierarchy of values?
And then more complex.
Lee,
when you integrate a state,
which is what the Mesopotamians did,
right?
The first great civilization.
What does that mean?
The first time hundreds of tribes were hammered into some sort of stable,
hierarchical order.
How do you represent that order?
So Marta gets his act together.
The gods all meet in a huge chamber.
They elect him king and then they prepare them for battle.
When the gods of the father's beheld the power of his word,
they were glad and didn't homage saying Martin is king.
They bestowed upon them a sceptre,
a throne,
and a royal robe.
They gave him an irresistible weapons,
fighting the enemy saying,
Golan cut off the life of tire.
Matt.
May the winds carry her blood out of the way.
Places after the gods.
His father's had determined the destiny of Marduk.
They said,
I'm on the road the way to success and attainment,
so then he goes to the heart of darkness,
so to speak,
and confronts tire.
Matt accuses her of treachery and challenges are to battle.
When Tom had heard this,
she became like one in a frenzy and lost her reason.
She cried out loud and furiously to the very roots or two legs,
shook back and forth.
She recited an incantation repeatedly casting her spell.
As for the gods of battle,
they sharpened their weapons Tiamat and Marduk the wisest of the gods advanced
against one another.
They pressed onto single combat and approached for battle.
Okay,
well things don't go out so well with time.
Matt,
from this point forward,
the first thing that Martech does,
it encapsulate her and then net,
and I think that's a really interesting metaphor because that's essentially what
human beings do when they encounter the unknown,
right?
They encapsulated in an explanatory network,
so it's a way of binding up the the anomaly or the unknown and giving it a
substandard form.
Then he cuts her into pieces.
Then he makes the world out of her pieces.
In fact,
one of Martin's names is he who makes ingenious things as a consequence of the
combat with ty and mapped out.
That's very,
very interesting because what it means is that the Samaritans are presenting in
metaphorical form the notion that when the chips are down,
the survival of being depends on the capacity of whatever Martech represents the
solar God to encounter the Matrix of being,
to cut it into pieces and to make the world.
And if you think about it in those terms,
it's a very,
very straightforward story,
right?
It's basically the story of human beings,
fundamentally the story of human beings because we,
in the words of a famous evolutionary psychologist whose name completely escapes
me.
We occupied the cognitive niche,
right?
Our motive being his creativity in the in the face of the unknown and when chaos
threatens the established motive being,
it's necessary for us to put our creativity into action and to carve out new
territory or territory as a consequence of encounter with the unknown.
Why?
Well,
because we can take the world apart with our hands and put it together in new
ways and then we can scold what we've done verbally and we can transmit it to
another person and then they can do the same thing and we're all doing this all
the time and we're all telling each other how we're doing it.
And that's how the embodiment of logos in the human being,
which is precisely equivalent to this Sumeria notion of Marta.
That's precisely how it is.
That we're constantly capable of redeeming the world.